and i think you two are better together
than you are apart well i work alone
or at least not with him let's just say
he's the boss i'm the boss when the boss
baby hit theaters back in the spring of
2017
it was a huge hit with audiences four
years later fans are able to reconnect
with ted and
tim templeton he's not a baby anymore we
have adult
ted the film's voice cast is stacked
with a-list stars and even some rising
ones
good today we're learning about the
behind the scenes of what went into
recording the boss baby
family business you're a baby
i repeat you're a baby
alec baldwin is one of the most highly
recognized actors working today
and he's certainly no stranger to voice
acting outside of voicing the titular
boss baby
ted templeton baldwin has lent his voice
to films like the spongebob squarepants
movie
this is what a real mustache looks like
as well as dreamworks rise of the
guardians i feel it
you may also know him from hit shows and
movies like 30 rock
saturday night live and the mission
impossible franchise
for their salvageable assets to the cia
a majority of the cast of boss baby
family business recorded their lines
from home
something that wasn't entirely new to
baldwin comparing the recording process
to how he records his podcast
despite this he says he still had to
experiment with what apps and equipment
he could use while recording his lines
baldwin uses his signature sly charm
when delivering this line while
bickering with his on-screen brother
james marsden
tim i'm going to give you the name of
the doctor
roy fetterman just tell him i sent you
okay
so much for brotherly love can i talk to
you in the kitchen
amy sedaris has made the rounds in
hollywood acting as well as providing
her voice to plenty of popular movies
and shows such as bojack horseman where
she voiced princess caroline
this could happen five more times but
i'm ready for that because i want this
the mandalorian and
elf like marsden sedaris is a new
addition to the cast
but unlike her new co-star she's voicing
an entirely new character
tina templeton the new boss baby in
charge who just so happens to be tim's
daughter
why do you need help using your phone
like baldwin sedaris started off her
voice work from home before moving to a
studio thanks to the pandemic
she expressed that the process was
difficult especially since she wasn't
working off anyone else's energy like
she was used to doing
she channels the hyperactive spirit of
tina during this scene where she
introduces herself to her dad
after she caused him to faint daddy
daddy daddy can you read me daddy daddy
debbie how many fingers am i holding up
in this humorous sequence ted finds
himself having to sneak through the
acorn center for advanced childhood
in order to reach the office of
mysterious and equally nefarious
dr edwin armstrong baldwin is able to
channel his inner irritated personality
during this moment where ted falls onto
a rather sticky carpet it's like they
always say
if you want something done right you
have to do it without your brother
while debriefing a babyfied ted and tim
on their mission to save babycorp tina
lets her father and
uncle know who's in charge sedaris
brings her signature snark that she
brought to many of her other characters
during this scene
well i'm the boss applesauce and i think
you two are better
together than you are apart talk about
bossy but that doesn't make sense for
this movie
sedaris claims that tina's zodiac sign
is most definitely
a virgo that claim definitely seems to
be true in this scene featuring her
revealing to tim that she's the new
boss baby yes baby corp is more of what
i call
a side hustle for me the point is i
am all in one on the templeton over the
course of the two boss baby movies alec
baldwin has been
full of one-liners while voicing the
role of ted
from the classic line that cookie down
cookies
are for closers to your father is a
hippie
baldwin doesn't miss when going for a
laugh with these lines
he gives one of his best liners yet in
this scene where he learns
dr armstrong's shocking secret surprise
surprise
what the frittata amy sedaris's tina
gives tim some brutal honesty in this
scene
sedaris has already played very business
forward characters before
as seen in her role on the netflix
animated series bojack horseman
here she brings the bluntness and
straightforward nature of being a boss
baby
even analyzing her own parents it looks
like sedaris may have even gone off
script while getting into character
you guys really know how to baby a baby
i mean it's incredible
now that it's all five star i say you
have a lot of issues
after all the craziness that went on
during his meeting with the evil dr
armstrong
ted gives the perfect response on his
way
well i think that went well it's the
kind of simple and empathetic delivery
that helps make this scene all the more
comedic
amy sedaris's tina isn't always as
business forward as she presents herself
to be in this scene where ted exclaims
to his brother that he may have finally
cracked the code on the whole parenting
thing she takes a moment to praise her
father albeit in a typical boss baby
fashion
gold star for you daddy now keep it up
pups
things get pretty heated in this moment
between baldwin and marsden as they
argue over whether tina can actually
talk or not what makes this scene all
the more impressive is that both of them
recorded their lines separately
suck it ted i thank your pardon you suck
no no tim
you suck in one of her first lines in
the film amy sedaris channels her inner
chucky when revealing to her dad that
she can actually talk
just like ted could when he was an
infant hi daddy
okay maybe that's not the best way to
introduce yourself
is that you as dr armstrong shows ted
around his secret
evil lair underneath the acorn center
baldwin's ted
asks a question that's probably on all
the audience's minds
as well in this self-aware comment um
so why bother with school you could go
public
and make millions during this moment sat
at the baby corp headquarters ted starts
to realize what tina's plan really is
and where he falls into it he gives the
same response that we'd all probably
have in this situation
wait wait wait wait wait you want me to
be a baby
they don't call it boss baby for nothing
ted but
teamwork doesn't seem work james marsden
has always been able to bring his
charisma throughout his career
starring in films like sonic the
hedgehog enchanted and playing marvel
superhero cyclops in the x-men franchise
like baldwin boss baby family business
isn't marsden's first voice acting role
but he is a new addition to the cast
regardless marsden is still able to show
some fatherly warmth when delivering the
lion's
opposite his boss baby daughter voiced
by amy sedaris
what is it this time huh kittens no this
time it's even
worse worse than kittens well he may not
have had the other actors to riff off
james marsden seemed to still be having
a great time recording his lines
while recording this fast-paced action
scene where tim and ted use a
rambunctious pony to get to the acorn
center
marsden was clearly showing off a lot of
energy
it must have been hard not to laugh at
baldwin's response
she can't talk tim tap it around again i
want to go
she can't talk to him the boss baby
family business cast
seemed to still find plenty of enjoyment
even when recording their lines in less
than usual circumstances
one is the loneliest number
we the people hopefully for the boss
baby 3
things will be back to normal do you
have a favorite boss baby quote
you